toyota was one of the first automakers
to embrace an easy future i mean how
could anyone forget the iconic toyota
prius the prius didn't have the best of
social images but it was and still is
one of the most cost-effective vehicles
on the road aside from pioneering the
way with hybrids toyota was also an
early investor in tesla way back in 2010
toyota invested 50 million dollars into
tesla which gave them a 1.43 take in the
company if they were still holding on to
this stake it would be worth over 10
billion dollars but unfortunately they
sold the stake in mid-2017
at the time it it seemed like toyota was
simply taking risk off the table and the
locking in profits
but looking back it seems like something
changed with toyota as they sold off
this stake since then toyota has
actually become more of an eevee opposer
for example toyota has actually been
lobbying to slow down the move to evs
they've also been behind the curve when
it comes to fully electric vehicles it
wasn't till april of 2022 that they
released their first fully electric suv
on the market and they've actually
recalled this vehicle due to the wheels
falling off so it's not exactly doing
great now supporters of toyota would
probably point out that toyota is
investing a significant amount into
battery technology for instance they
have a plan to invest 13.5 billion
dollars into battery tech by the end of
the decade but compared to the rest of
the industry this is rather
underwhelming take ford for example ford
is literally drowning in debt with over
200 billion dollars in liabilities yet
they just increased their ev investment
from 30 billion through 2026 to 50
billion dollars similarly volkswagen is
investing
and 180 billion dollars into ev usa over
the next four years considering these
investments toyota's commitment is
rather underwhelming clearly it they
haven't ditched evie's altogether but at
the same time they're also refusing to
go all in and jump onto the eevee
bandwagon so why is toyota so hesitant
with evs
one of the main reasons toyota has been
so hesitant when it comes to evs is
because they've been betting on hydrogen
according to toyota's vice chairman they
don't want to be seen as an ev maker but
as a carbon neutral company toyota
argues that this carbon neutral future
does not need to be achieved with evs
carbon neutrality is not about having a
single choice but about keeping options
open this in itself is not a bad stance
per se but thus far we've only seen
issues when it comes to hydrogen
vehicles take the 2021 tokyo olympics
for example toyota supply the olympics
with 500 hydrogen buses and cars the
vehicles themselves worked all right but
the same it could not be said about
their finances you see toyota leased out
these buses to japan for 900 000 for six
years a comparable diesel bus could have
been leased out for 220 000 for 15 years
on an annual basis the hydrogen bus
works out to 150 thousand dollars per
year while the diesel bus works out to
under 15 000 per year in other words the
hydrogen option is literally 10 times as
expensive and that's just the least
unlike evs where fueling up is
dramatically cheaper than gas
counterparts with these hydrogen buses
it's actually 2.6 times more expensive
if you thought evs were already
expensive these are clearly on a
different level to make things worse
financial concerns are just the first of
your worries hydrogen vehicles also
suffer from an extremely underdeveloped
refueling network unlike electric
charging you can't just set up a few
charging stations that link up their
local power grid instead you have to buy
hydrogen-specific fuel dispensers that
often cost a hundred thousand dollars
per unit you also have to spend a
significant amount on storing the
hydrogen and you also have to deal with
regular hydrogen deliveries in other
words you basically have to run a gas
station and given that the majority of
gas stations make their money off of the
convenience stores attached to the gas
stations i don't think they'll be
particularly thrilled to invest into
hydrogen infrastructure one advantage
that should be pointed out however is
that filling up a hydrogen vehicle is
similar to filling up a gas vehicle
meaning that you can get a full tank of
gas within just three to five minutes
if you're someone who does a lot of road
trips this is likely a significant
advantage but that's pretty much where
the advantages end and it's not just a
fueling process that's similar between
gas vehicles and hydrogen vehicles the
maintenance process is also quite
similar you see hydrogen vehicles are
way more complex than evs meaning that
they naturally come along with more
maintenance given that more things can
go wrong so hydrogen vehicles just don't
stack up against evs but then why is
toyota so determined to go down this
path well the answer seems to lie in
what's best for japan as opposed to
what's best for everyone else
japan's obsession with hydrogen is
nothing new
in fact it's just one of many avenues
that japan has been experimenting with
for decades
and the main reason the country does not
want to ban to western standards is
because of the country's energy
dependence japan is basically just an
island which means that they don't have
any neighboring countries at first
glance this might seem cool they have
this entire piece of land all to
themselves but logistically this is
actually a nightmare here's the thing
when you aren't physically attached to
any other countries shipping becomes
extremely difficult because everything
has to be shipped through the sea
and this is especially a problem when
we're talking about energy
you see it much of the world that either
creates their own energy or they rely on
neighboring countries
europe for example used to rely on
russia for crude oil and natural gas
they had a massive set of pipelines that
facilitated trade between these two
regions a similar case can be seen with
america as well canada is the largest
energy exporter to america and the
reasoning is obvious the two countries
are touching which makes it easy to
trade energy japan obviously does not
have any such partners they also don't
have any of the high demand resources
like crude oil or natural gas so they've
essentially been forced into importing
all of their energy this is not only
expensive but it also puts japan at a
massive trading disadvantage i mean when
you're importing at 94 percent of your
energy you're not exactly in the best
position to implement tariffs or start a
trade war the other countries could head
back with an energy boycott near country
would be screwed within a matter of days
japan is obviously not a fan of this
situation and they've been trying to
escape for decades
their initial solution to this conundrum
was going all-in on nuclear energy and
this was actually playing out really
well
at their peak in 2010 they were able to
produce 13 of the entire country's
energy needs using nuclear power but all
of this would come crashing down in 2011
with the fukushima nuclear disaster you
probably heard about this on the news
154 000 people had to be evacuated and
it's ranked as the second worst nuclear
disaster of all time only be nod by
chernobyl the worst part is that japan
couldn't have even done anything about
it it's not like the disaster was caused
by mismanagement or negligence it was
actually caused by a record-breaking
earthquake plus tsunami combination
really the only way japan could have
avoided this disaster was to not support
nuclear energy in the first place and
that's exactly what they've been trying
to do ever since but this has catapulted
the entire country into a perpetual
energy crisis nowadays it's extremely
common for japan to issue power
conservation messages to households and
companies as the country is constantly
fighting to avoid blackouts as you would
guess japan has been frantically looking
for solutions ever since the disaster
and the top solution they've landed on
it is hydrogen
while japan does not have access to any
of the common sources of energy what
they do have access to is hydrogen for
once japan's ocean surroundings are
actually helpful you see it the ocean
floor surrounding japan is filled with
the sherbet like substance often
referred to as fire ice
these ice crystals hold a tremendous
amount of natural methane which can be
converted into even more hydrogen it's
estimated that just one cubic meter of
methane hydrate can produce 160 cubic
meters of methane gas which can then be
turned into hydrogen and given that
japan has an exclusive economic zone
that stretches to both sides of the
country you have access to plenty of
fire ice
now it's not all sunshines and rainbows
given that it's not easy to extract fire
ice first you have to voyage deep into
the ocean where the seafloor is a
thousand meters under the surface from
there you have to drill hundreds of
meters into the seabed to actually
retrieve the fire ice japan has been
working out on a new drilling method
that can potentially extract fire ice
from shallower locations and then send
them through underwater pipelines but
this is still a work in progress
it's not clear if this new process will
work out but it doesn't matter whether
it does or not for the first time in a
long time japan actually has an
alternative form of energy and if this
process doesn't work out they're just
going to keep trying different processes
until they figure out something that
does work for them this is not a matter
of oh let's switch to renewable energy
because it's the right thing to do it
and it's trendy
now for them this is a matter of we have
to figure this out asap if we want to
save japan from the energy crisis
so they're obviously taking this
extremely seriously and as japan's
largest company toyota is obviously
doing everything they can to support
this division and yes that includes law
in other countries to slow down eevee
adoption when you look at it from the
western perspective it seems like toyota
is the bad guys who are teaming up with
the all giants like shell and exxon to
stall this wholesome movement towards
evs but that's not really the case at
all toyota isn't against renewable
energy or evs they're simply trying to
promote the form of energy that would be
most beneficial for their own country
global energy changes don't happen often
if anything they might happen once a
century so we're truly living through
historic times and japan only has one
shot at getting this right either they
convinced the world that hydrogen is
worth pursuing right now
or they get left behind as the entire
world switches to evs
if this happens japan would just become
even more dependent on energy imports
also allocating a significant portion of
their electricity towards running
electric cars will simply increase their
chances of a blackout even more so
that's the last thing japan wants to do
something else that we should note is
that japan is not even the country that
would benefit most from a switch to
hydrogen
it's not like japan has so much hydrogen
that they would become the next saudi
arabia or something rather a trend
towards hydrogen would simply alleviate
their dependency for energy the country
that would really profit from the switch
is china who is leader in hydrogen
production and consumption china's
current hydrogen usage comes in at a
whopping at 24 million tons per year now
it should be noted that most of this
hydrogen is great hydrogen meaning that
it's produced using fossil fuels but
china is setting up loads of green
hydrogen plants as we speak so they
would be the ones that would benefit
most from such a transition so in the
end why is toyota refusing to jump onto
the eevee bandwagon despite pioneering
the industry
well their home country japan has been
struggling with energy for decades and
there has recently been a glimmer of
hope with hydrogen so they're trying
their best to leverage this opportunity
and maximize the benefit for japan but
only time will tell it if this gamble
will be worth it now that you can see it
from japan's perspective do you think
toyota is doing the wrong thing comment
that down below
also drop a like if you hope that japan
is able to overcome their energy crisis
and of course consider checking out our
discord community to suggest after video
ideas and consider subscribing see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one